viendront sachent wazi aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur ce poste voie le coup et ça
fait super longtemps que je vais te
faire ce quiz de problème c'est qu'il
est en anglais mais grâce au niveau que
j'ai acquis en anglais grâce à toutes
ces vidéos datées et vous c'est parti le
principe est très simple on répond à des
questions on a trois vies et quand on
fait trois mauvaises réponses on
recommence le quiz depuis le début ce
qui est très désagréable ou mais at il
de trop un polo 4-way aller saluer ce
qu'une allumette peut boxer je crois que
ça lui met with men qui a défoncé mike
tyson on a perdu une librairie voilà
c'est comme ça que ça se passe très
agréable non mais une boîte peu après un
oui monsieur ou une équipe qui essaie
que ce phoque boîte tennis elbow
je ne comprends pas qu est en bas ça
nous a mis ko aux normes mais quoi c'est
à la pure chance
allez allez c'est reparti bas c'est quoi
avec j'ai fait toutes les possibilités
mais moi [ __ ] je sorte qu'ils savent
faire complètement craqué ce je clique
sur la rive omet à ok d'accord c'est ça
ça veut jouer le four mais aucun
problème j'ai habitudes la réponse est
très grosse south est marquée en énorme
savoia marqué très gros ça ou c'est
l'infini et south est un éléphant se
vendent entre ces deux là un éléphant
mais où est la difficulté la chambre en
porsche cherche
j'aurais dû me taire c'est pas un truc
en titre encore ça au espèce de petit
bâtard de salles au double c ou c ou c
ou je comprends pas là c'est un kiff
leur nom y est ce qu'elle est et la
réponse de la question numéro 2 en plus
il met des flèches quoi se dire que si
on si on met that one syndic celle là en
fait à l'opus 3i la nourriture à ok
comme la souris dessus ça change et ça
fait une pomme là ça fait du beurre là
ça fait une chaise la sa le beurre au
monsieur nous on est carrément qu'on
sait pas possible ce qui se passe qu'est
ce qui suit le 2 décembre 23 décembre
impute un mec c'est trop c'est trop
évident pour qu'il soit envoyé là c'est
la douleur où il faut tout refaire
j'ai un bonus pour saper une question si
je veux ça c'est bon ça c'est très bon
s'ils sont très très fourbe cn parce que
ce qui suit le 2 c'est le n 1 point
d'interrogation se passer faut gérer ça
où aller n appuie son plus petit qu il
peut y avoir un piège mec
celui-là non moi je suis fort donc je
possède en fait plus grosses chaleurs
donc j'ai pas fait oh c'est pas celui-là
mais c'est sûr et certain ya pas un il
un point là sur cette bonne avec ba
voila tout au plus je juge degré
hallyday mais je n'ai pas le bon quel
est le son d'une cloche groupe
sting front bly bla bla bla ou 20 babol
au stade je pensais qu'il avait un truc
n'importe quoi ah qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez mettre dans un seau pour le
rendre plus léger des gitans pourquoi
une torche sas un jeune grec lighters
que leicester samedi à briquet en
anglais un trou ou une canette de rire
et ce qu'ils n'ont pas joué sur jeu de
mots we saw rhinos keeping si je skie
php rend pas ce qui fait quoi et bloque
pas mais monsieur set up pratiquer
l'humour de plus de la vidéo mais là
plus d'humour quoi s'était pas levé à
temps mais on va pas réussi jusqu'à ce
qu'on essaie toutes les lettres wells à
ce doit être un truc cacher encore ça le
point le produit car oui j'ai aucune
répartie j'ai aucune idée jeux
l'utilisant boucle le u
mais comment voulez vous qu'on fasse
quoi google traduction tu peux m'aider
ou pas pour ça non ok ça marche pas du
tout j'ai tout essayé fait chier mêmes
têtes f comme fuck you et banon sur la
queue du cheval
non peut-être que je peux baisser le no
string en restant sur le clic qu'est ce
que ça peut être à la fin tu es un truc
qui ressemble au cheval une lettre d'un
méchant des théories ridicule kouao
peut-être la lettre qu'il ya le plus
dans ce mot là il ya trois fois les deux
mêmes lettres là dans ces trucs là ça
c'est de la merde ça merde là se fera
sur une théorie du complot version sur
ce site c'est ridicule ash ouais ok h et
maintenant qu'est-ce qui vous fait faire
des bonds donc les entorses aux hauts
atteints j'ai peur du piège on s'en f
quand je ris pas tu es parti c'était
débile quelle est la septième lettres de
l'alphabet a b c d e f g
je ne pouvais pas être sa tâche je sais
pas j'ai pas compris pourquoi 24 mois
7,18 totalement fausse et où 17 s'il
vous plaît 17 à ben arfa alors là vous
voyez à théorie du poids la marche et
cette fois c'est cette [ __ ] de
questions aux essais et aux attractions
tu te cap direct stop quoi au nom même
mec mais ça ça n'a aucun sens le marteau
coloris dans le bon ordre
alors je suis très fort en dessin tu t'y
prends mal avec moi je ne suis moi j'ai
mis du bleu puis j'ai perdu de vie puis
j'ai zappé la question j'ai pas de
courage - deal ou pas ils allaient
nocives
et ben voilà dil donc c'était tout en
bas à gauche s'il way regarde
attentivement c'était tout qu'on aime
voir clignoter là haut au plus j'avais
totalement vu la couleur j'étais sûr que
c'est cette case le choix tu appartiens
plus élevé - une vie plus sain suivant
escales et skype c'est intrigant des
fois je fais des fois je comprends rien
je fais un truc qu il se positionne
aussi des fois ci on va très vite on
pourra voir click the v in lines voilà
allez merci comme en tutu un loup garou
avec du cirage des granules de sauce du
boudin noir ou du cillit bang c'est
lidberg michael va c'est le seul truc
c'est à benguet s'aimer vie apparemment
avec du boudin noir
je suis totalement dingue vu tout ce que
je dois me retaper 20 [ __ ] de
questions dans le nord-mali donc ici
donc c'est pas du goût du site banni du
boudin noir donc c'est quoi du cirage
ok ok laquelle de ces places n'existent
pas eh bien beach oui c'est à dire le
champ des prostituées le champ des dd
beach et n'existent pas eh ben non c'est
faux à ce fauteuil au oui ok il me
devait plus leur la question quoi vos
mots je voulais vous dire justement
j'espère que tu as été vraiment attentif
aux numéros de la question au nom je
crois que c'est la 25e
moi j'adore vraiment offert si les
choses qui me passionnent vraiment
qu'elle faisait que stark enjeux
traduire balle est bonne
google me dis bonne balle et très bien
ça me plaît beaucoup
voilà c'est ta faute encore un gâteau
féerique c'est ça à l'époque est quelque
chose de très cruel au mec c'était le
seul joker on s'en fout on s'en fout ça
intéresse personne c'est-à-dire lucas je
suis dans le futur et je te quitte on
s'en fout quelle saveur et temps carton
le miel les ea mayonnaise les
grattements de porda fuck et le talk bas
le talk des grattements port le miel
je t'emmerde lui cacher dans le passé je
suis en chemin inquiète pas j'arrive là
vraiment je fais tout ce que je peux
c'est les yeux à la mayonnaise mais non
mais c'est génial les halls mayonnaise
monga met à sourire ici maintenant ne
touche pas le vert il ya aucun problème
à l'acheteur fait ça mais à l'école
primaire au caire mais c'est tout il m'a
dit trois fois ouaf ouaf va chier bref
on chauffe
oui oui au fait vous savez décidé à le
chien ils nous regardent et manon était
pas confiance du tout quels sont les
ingrédients principaux du shampoing les
criques et baby shine et les têtes
d'humains des pierres et des saucisses
ou des chats je sais pas quoi de pire à
des saucisses maintenant monsieur
comment au bout
je vous avoue que là ça commençait à
faire extrêmement long de revient là on
en est et ce concept réservant sur toi
c'est les chat avec le criquet c'est
l'humain faille 6 voiles indique alger
plus qu'une vieille salut combien de
lettres il y a dans sa main 4 6 8 9
c'est scandaleux voilà agnès désolé je
sais pas pourquoi tu est scandaleuse il
en a neuf réellement après sa main est
coupée il ya peut-être un piège de quoi
mettre 10 il n'y a pas d'explication
quoi c'est juste beau trop reculé les
éléphants n'aime pas maïs je dois faire
quoi quelques années le fuck là j'ai pas
suivi
qu'est ce que tu appelles un vol sans
elle le flap une marche
jason une plume jason suis pas pourquoi
il m'a tirée c'est le flap les marches
ouais toutefois c'est plutôt logique
mais bon on sait pas on sait jamais ça
problème est ce que tu peux avoir faut à
cette question et pas moyen
marié grau s'est assis sur une épingle à
aa en bas de chez moi je veux pas être
méchant mais alors du coup en vraiment
secret est horrible alors je me moque
pas je m'inquiète pas marie rose voilà
c'est ça qu'est ce que c'est que ça
walter white la fac aventure cylindrique
ah bah oui bah c'est évident ne touche
pas le rose je vais mais quel effet je
fais comment match avec à du rhône entre
les deux tu vas pas les appeler la
question est injuste qu'ils soient
directs quel est le phoque
l'ale l'afro cliquez là les fesses de la
bad en là faut cliquer ou qu'est ce que
c'est que ce visite
donc cela amène sur ça voilà ça a
quelque chose de passionnant espèce m'a
fait passer la latte même pas mais
[ __ ] on sait même plus marrer c'est la
fois les eaux et la réponse à la vie à
l'univers et à tout indice ses 42 faut
cliquer sur ce 40 dollars non non pas
deux fois à 6,40 dollars non plombé stay
the path où commence et où je vais
réfléchir très longtemps c'est quoi oye
ce mec
si avec des petits stratégie de fonds
sino les fons abattoirs bridget rend
tout le monde guette tom cruise be
normal alors de quel budget on parle ici
on parle de ciel bridge est là je dirais
normal si on parle de cette budget la
tâche en tant qu'image sa fiche pour
vous comprenez la blague
si on parle de cette budget la lasser
d'un coup c'est plus bizarre donc que
tom cruise a on peut déplacer les trucs
je suis en train de faire mon vieux
puzzle qu'on a tardé quoi clic pierre o
c'est beau c'est beau mais t'es chiant
quand même un calme toi créateur ça par
exemple c'est beaucoup moins bon je vais
souvent du doigt dans l'oeil donc je
vais prendre celui-là
ah [ __ ] sur la droite c'est quoi ça
quelqu un couple née de sony que c'est
sérieux
y'a pas moyen de le remettre son nez ou
texte si on est devenu le point de la
question
j'en veux plus ok je fais ce que je peux
ouais même j'ai lu qu'il sony kayes
[ __ ] on est à la 40' via 110 question
totale ou presque à moitié
quelle est la manière correcte de
l'épaule et l'api du pape un fac c'est
trop j'en ai pas et je suis moi pardon
palais mais pas la fin mais quand vous
allez me crier pas dessus par dessus moi
je refais ya aucun problème alors nous y
revoilà change mais un gamin c'est quoi
le cela peut me do when on a plus de vie
elle est nickel
je deviens toi ok 40 on est presque à la
moitié 55 moi j'arrête c'est moi j'ai
fait ma journée à tanger pas de monter
au fdp alors carottes dans la terre on
va regarder la gueule ça on va faire
quoi que ce soit je veux pas perdre ça
ressemble à ça
ce bal premier cycle et emballe deuxième
gex et lui un assez pas facile du tout
fermé tiré au cas où marmite
what is at the fame ait nos gammes urgo
je veux arriver à la moitié à 55 vous
avez de la chance et on s'assoit
correctement le cas si tu veux ou sur le
pas de manière dont j'ai qu'une vie en
pop hip hop là haut
c'était une beauté au gas from 6 à 3
fois de suite c'est rejet en appel
oui allô maman quel est le système
digestif non oh il reste ça y'est on est
50 sismiques et voilà les gens c'est
déjà phone 7 vous rappelle péter jaks
l'ancien prix cher cela on va se calmer
j'ai donc c'est déjà la fin de cette
vidéo
je suis assez les apus sega n'hésitez
pas allez mais moi ça m'a pas plu du
tout je vous emmerde tous on est a fait
55 questions sur 110 est hors de
question que je fasse du dosage vous le
dis j'ai pu avoir une pétition où une
bombe même qui je m'en fous vous vous
débrouillez cvo conflit moi je vais
tranquillement me mettre dans mon
jacuzzi justice'' du mois souhaitent
c'est ma ma place en fait mais ça aurait
gardé un certain travail dans une
prochaine vidéo chat ou monde à bientôt
pis